the US Olympic Committee is demanding
all USA Gymnastics board members resign
over the Larry Nasser sexual abuse
scandal more than 150 women and girls
including numerous athletes and Olympic
Olympic gymnast accused the former US
women's gymnastics team doctor of abuse
a judge sentenced Nasser to up to 175
years in prison the Olympic Committee
says if board members do not resign by
Wednesday the gymnastics governing board
will lose its national status four of
the 21 board members have already
stepped down USA Gymnastics said it
embraces the requirements dr. Jon LaPook
has been following the story and joins
us once again at the table we said
yesterday there's certainly more to come
there certainly is
Larry Nasser worked for Michigan State
University and after his sentencing the
president stepped down today the
Michigan State Board of Trustees will
meet and hundreds of students are
expected to protest for many the
leadership changes at USA Gymnastics and
Michigan State University are not enough
what's your message to the msu board
thank you for making it abundantly clear
where you stand
victims rachel den Hollander and Kyle
Stephens told Norah O'Donnell they are
not satisfied with the school's response
especially after trustee Joel Ferguson
made what he later called an inadvertent
comment about Michigan State University
president Lou Anna Simon there's so many
more things going to the university
Michigan State University is continuing
the abuse Carl so by not taking
responsibility for their actions they
still have not issued an apology in Lou
Anna Simon she stepped down but her
statement when she resigned was not
apologetic Simon did say she was sorry
that a trusted renowned physician was
really such an evil evil person and
acknowledged that as president it is
only natural that I am the focus of this
anger according to her contract she's
still entitled to several perks
including the option to receive her
seven hundred and fifty thousand dollar
salary for a year if she returns to the
faculty that's in addition to lifetime
parking passes and football tickets if
the right
done then 20 years ago I should have
never met the sad excuse for a man
even as Nasser sentencing wrapped up
this week Michigan State and USA
Gymnastics defended themselves in
another court in a federal lawsuit
victims alleged neglect and other
charges describing multiple occasions in
which they reported abuse as early as
1997 the defendants have asked the judge
to dismiss the case arguing state
institutions like MSU are generally
immune from suit and saying USA
Gymnastics did not have a legal duty to
report the allegations everyone should
have an obligation to report suspicions
of child abuse or neglect
Marissa quit Kowski is one of the
reporters who first broke the news about
NASA in the Indianapolis Star we're
looking at the entirety of the system
because failures to report child sexual
abuse happen at every level four years
michigan state university has been under
federal oversight for what for having
what the feds call a sexually hostile
environment michigan state university
implemented changes but according to
ESPN the government rejected its request
to end the oversight due in large part
to its handling of the Nasr case the US
Department of Education is now
reportedly investigating Michigan State
University's handling of Nasr complaints
you know when an animal is under attack
it's a natural instinct to go into a
defensive posture when that instinct
takes place in an institution that's
employing somebody who's accused of
sexual abuse that's a very bad instinct
and what you're seeing now is that
defensive posture being pried over they
don't have much of a difference it seems
on this particular case John thank you
so thank you very much